what son forgets Mother's Day yeah buy
me some bath salts is that so difficult
I would like one mothers take on candle
something at this stage it doesn't feel
like motherhood it feels like other hood
that is the best description I've ever
heard what are we gonna do drive to
Manhattan storm their apartments now we
gotta with some individuate blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah except some
Mother's Day we're not on vacation we
are on a mission we are going to
reconnect with our sons you didn't call
me on Mother's Day I texted you hi boss
cute they can deal with having us in
their homes for a few days
they run ours for 18 years so I care
what the end goal of scale was cooking
you won't even have to work I have a
party tonight Oh mother's invited no I
mean no we're in the mill in New York
City we are going clubbing
bingo clubbing when I was supposed to go
clubbing what do we even get into what
well I didn't think I'd get any of these
jeans look at me now what is that move
twerking without me I need to figure out
who I am without you
[Music]
where have you been hiding those
this big bruise beautiful thing this is
your life I'm not trying to tell you
what to do that's why since today
you taught me there is room in every
story for a better ending you will
always be my mother thanks
you know how long it's been since I had
sex I was gonna say pizza
[Music]
you
you